we have a repatriation of ancient
artifacts from Egypt it includes a child
sarcophagus about 2600 years old the top
of another mummy sarcophagus a burial
shroud from inside a mummy sarcophagus
and finally there is a mummified hand
which was collected from a sci-fi studio
in Los Angeles it's quite an unusual
piece if you look closely at the hand
you see the most detailed fingernails
and wrinkles on the knuckles I'm pretty
sure as soon as they opened the box they
said um this is not a prop this is a
real mummified hand
we have an abundance of human heritage
in antiquities and it's so abundant and
has been grey to illicit trafficking and
I'm taking advantage of turbulent ears
of the Arab Spring you've also seen the
destruction of Antiquities in Iraq and
Syria and this has all highlighted the
importance that we all come together to
protect these invaluable pieces of art I
am so honored I'm so happy to host a
verification for the hour and objects
our antiquities to retain our treasures
back home to preserve their treasures
cultural heritage is a non-renewable
resource
once these artifacts get ripped from the
ground then the history of that object
and their context just disappears we are
really proud to be part of helping these
objects return home they belong to Egypt
and for us to be able to return them and
say these are more at home in Egypt than
they are in somebody's private
collections in the United States is a
really important thing to note
[Music]